oh
o o
[Musique]
michel noir est ce que vous vous êtes un
jour imaginé président de la république
je ne formulerai pas comme ça je dirais
un jour je me suis dit qu'est ce qu'il y
aurait à faire d essentielle que je
serai capable sans doute de faire si
j'avais une autre responsabilité que
d'être ministre ou maire d'une ville et
vous auriez pu être président de la
république c'est ce que vous vous êtes
dit c'est ce que disait en tout cas les
médias les sondages et est ce que c'est
dans ma tête n'était pas absent puisque
j'étais sur une trajectoire hommes de
pouvoir visiter sensible à ce que
disaient les médias au point de que les
médias vous persuade que vous pouviez de
président de la république annoncé par
les médias qui me persuade
personnellement du jour où je suis entré
en politique j'ai eu envie de servir est
un homme d'action de faire bouger les
choses comme vous êtes entré en
politique vous êtes dit un des adjectifs
ça peut être devenir l'instar de la
république
non sûrement pas j'étais étudiant
gaulliste à 18 ans rue saint guillaume
je pensais pas du tout alors vous avez
une ascension fulgurante 1 vous avez été
député à ces jeunes 1960 et puis vous
avez été réélu cinq fois vous avez été
ministre
vous étiez prêts à tout pour avoir le
pouvoir pour le posséder pour le
conquérir
non seulement pas parce que pour moi le
pouvoir n'est pas une pathologie dont on
est la victime en quelque sorte le
patient a en effet l'acteur on le
pouvoir c'est un instrument qui permet
d'agir en fonction d'objectifs qu'on
peut définir comme étant le bien commun
l'intérêt en que je sorte de alors nous
l'avez dit vous étiez gaulliste visite
est de droite
et qu'est-ce que vous entendre de droite
oui qu'est-ce que vous entendiez un
carnet de plus que les autres dans le
paysage politique
rien de plus que les autres ce que je
l'imaginais c'était agir dans ce qui
pour moi conseiller et lé les points
majeurs de swat dysfonctionnements
soi-même de j'allais dire le nouveau de
maladie ont par exemple j'ai toujours
été obsédé par l'idée que quand une
société fabrique 15 à 20% d'exclusion
sociale
c'est que l 'est pas réussir l'enfant et
donc il ya un problème de système et du
caroubier servir l'intérêt général et
puis il ya quelque chose qui vous a
marqué qu'on vous a collé comme
étiquette c'est que vous vouliez
incarner la droite morale
pourquoi parce qu'il ya eu cette tribune
dans le monde en 1987
mieux vaut perdre une élection que de
perdre son âme
ça ça vous a collé à la peau quand même
c'est ma colère est beau mais ça c c'est
profondément ce que je suis parce que
moi je je suis né à mathausen si je puis
dire entre guillemets c'est à dire que
moi je n'ai mon père
les résistants et déportés à mathausen
il me va me découvrir
un an après ma naissance et mon père m'a
toujours dit n'oublie jamais mathausen
sert ce que ça signifie ce drame humain
que deux des sociétés de l'humanité qui
consiste à refuser l'autre dans les
pires formes parce que vous dites ça et
vous écrivez ça parce qu'il ya un
contexte on est en pleine période de
montée du front national il ya eu cette
barbie et le front national
comment continue à monter c'est ça qui
vous pousse à valider cette phrase me
souviens très bien que ces 2 le 13 mai à
23 heures je me mets à écrire ceci j'ai
assisté la veille à une séance du procès
de klaus barbie ce qui a remué beaucoup
de choses en moi puisque ça a été
vraiment la partie la plus forte de mon
éducation entre guillemets c'est
pourquoi je dis j'ai aucun mérite d'être
dans et j'ai craché cet article parce
que je sentais à la fois que les gens du
front national et jenny front national
manifester de l'autre côté de la saône
en face du ps ju s'ils souhaitaient où
était jugé klaus barbie
c'était quelque chose d'inacceptable
et est-ce que vous redoutiez que votre
parti politique était le rpr à l'époque
qui était dirigée par jacques chirac
puisse pactiser avec le front national
précisément peut-être pas tous partis
mais certains d'entre eux j'étais bien
puisque j'étais aussi l'un des
dirigeants
je savais très bien que
pour jacques chirac il m'a dit un jour
tél tél
au lendemain de mon papier il n'était
pas très très heureux il m'a dit moi je
préfère une stratégie pasqua lequel
disait nous partageons les mêmes valeurs
que le front national ce qui m'avait
fait me sortir de mes gonds et ça
faisait aussi partie de ceux de cette
sorte de 2,2 noeud gordien qui s'est
noué dans ces jours de mai puisqu'on
était déjà en train de préparer dans la
tête
l'élection présidentielle dont cas là il
y avait il y avait en l'occurrence au
sein de deux des dirigeants il y avait
deux thèses qui se défend qui
s'affrontaient alors est ce que c'est
cette différence de vue cette divergence
de vues avec jacques chirac charles
pasqua qui vous conduit dire petit à
petit votre réflexion se dérouler mais
vous dit basta d'abord on a perdu deux
élections 1988 élections présidentielles
1981 l'élection présidentielle il faut
changer le logiciel
il faut changer les hommes et est ce que
c'est ça qui vous conduit à ce que vous
avez regardez maintenant tout a commencé
il y a deux semaines charles millon udf
appel à la rénovation
en clair les jeunes de l'opposition ne
veulent pas de giscard comme tête de
liste
si sud et f6 rpr tous cadrage nerfs sont
décidés à jouer leur carte et empêcher
les centristes de constituer leur propre
liste
chacun a ses raisons conseil national du
rpr la motion rénovatrice présenté par
michel noir
recueil à peine 13% des voix la ligne
noire seguin s'affirme mais elle est et
reste minoritaire
les rénovateurs n'iront sur aucune des
deux listes en présence
ils sont aujourd'hui volontairement sur
la touche peu leur importe ils ont
secoué le cocotier et pris date pour
l'avenir
vous avez secouer le cocotier vous
sauver de cette période vous vouliez
chasser giscard chirac barre la vieille
garde de la droite
c'était pas du tout chasser c'était de
dire arrêtez de faire semblant d'être
d'accord et de vous opposer puisque ça
c'est la machine à perdre donc arrêter
de perdre les élections parce que nous
on n'est pas en politique avec un goût
forcené de l'échec électoral notamment
quand on se dévoue corps et âme pour un
leader ce qui est normal d'ailleurs
qu'on suive un leader et qu'on est un
champion lors d'une élection mais
bon quand on a perdu deux fois une
présidentielle quand en plus aux
législatives de 88 après avoir perdu
suite à la réélection de françois
mitterrand on perd les législatives
parce que on a eu une attitude très
équivoque à l'égard du front national à
preuve les accords qui sont passé en
douce pardon de l'expression simple en
douce avec le front national dans le
midi de la france
ce qui nous a coûté l'élection de jeudi
parce que les français dans le fond il
se dédie on sait bien on a un président
françois mitterrand
c'est un peu le grand-père le sage et
puis on a des gens qui voient ainsi tout
cas c'est là quand même
donc le prendre le pouvoir en
l'occurrence on disait on va établir un
rapport de force pour faire comprendre
que on est pas là pour subir ce qu'est
cet affrontement d'ego qui fait que
chacun n'est pas capable de l'ain le lay
avait six idf si rpr on vous appelez les
douze salopards dans la presse ça veut
dire qu'on a une culture
cinématographique à la mêlée c'est douze
salopards là est-ce qu'ils étaient
vraiment d'accord entre d'ailleurs vous
seriez battu entre vous après si ça
marche et ça échoue et ça je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas on est en faisait le
même diagnostic
ce qui motivait un plan d'action qui
consistait à peser en disant arrêter les
conneries
pardon l'expression mais ça faisait dix
ans que ça dure et donc et si on les
prend 1
léotard vous carignon fillon la suite de
leur histoire était conflictuelle
séguin c'est bien il est mort mais la
suite de leur histoire était compliqué
ah oui mais ça c'est le propre du destin
d'une vie quoi y aller alors des
événements des circonstances des drames
même
tout ce que vous faites est ce que vous
écrivez dans cette période là c'est une
dire il faut pas être dogmatique il faut
pas être cantonné à son camp il faut pas
être complètement enfermé vous êtes
plutôt un homme d'ouverture vous êtes
considéré comme ça trente ans après
finalement il ya un type qui a réussi
cette énième macron dont bien sûr est ce
que vous avez est-ce que macron c'est ce
que vous vouliez faire à l'époque
en tout cas c'est ce que j'imaginais à
savoir que tant qu'on serait dans ce
système binaire d'affrontements et qui
plus est à l'intérieur
dans des querelles d'abord ne serait pas
la garantie qu on ne penserait qu'à une
seule chose c'est que ce qui est à faire
à conduire une politique pour réussir à
faire évoluer la france puisqu'il faut
évoluer
eh bien tant qu'on serait dans ce
système les français petit à petit ce
raid
insatisfait et récuse rers en quelque
sorte de cette sorte d'affrontement
et finalement c'est ça c'est ce qu'avait
été la campagne de kennedy d'ailleurs se
doit tout bébé plutôt que l'opposition
très rock'n'roll area kennedy vous
donnerai pas les dix français les et
finalement 30 ans plus tard c'est ce que
macron alors lui compte tenu de ce qui a
été l'état encore plus avancé de la
décomposition en tout cas d'échec et de
crispations et des
et de la gauche essentiellement autour
du parti socialiste et de la droite
macron a dit il ya sûrement un meilleur
une meilleure voie consiste à proposer
aux français de dire bon arrêtons ces
oppositions
parce que le bien commun il est fait
d'un mixte entre des choses qui sont
propres
plutôt identifiés par la droite et des
choses ils sont plutôt identifiés par la
gauche donc on peut être des gens
soucieux de performance économique mais
dans une dimension de justice sociale et
c'est d'ailleurs la définition du
gaullisme vous pourriez être un jour où
aujourd'hui même vous pourriez être le
ministre un des ministres de macron
dérangera pas sur le plan de la
politique est conduite bien sûr bien sûr
parce que mais c'est un autre sujet de
dire est ce que j'aurai encore envie de
temps politique alors j'ai lu quelque
part que vous avez dit que fillon avait
suscité la droite c'est ça oui parce que
le gel est fini la droite aujourd'hui où
maintenant où c'est là qu'on la doit
mais aujourd'hui les la question et
n'existe plus si je puis dire
à savoir que les dents les l'opinion
s'est constitué est ce que ce sera
volatile ou pas à une sorte de
conglomérat de motivation et de deux
profils socioprofessionnels au tour de
ski identifie macron et au delà de ce
qui dans le passé
identifier des gens soient de droite des
gens soient de gauche
est ce que le pouvoir il faut une
stratégie pour avoir le pouvoir il faut
une stratégie est ce que c'est un peu
comme une partie d'échecs pour la
conquête oui oui à coup sûr puisqu'il
s'agit d'eux que le roi gagne mais la
vraie question c'est pour cela par dont
la relégation c'est à quoi sert le
pouvoir ou ou pourquoi elle tend au
pouvoir soit c'est une pathologie et ça
vous conduit à a
ce qui est assez fréquent jusqu'en et
s'emploie à savoir cumul de mandats et
inamovibilité c'est à dire je meurs à
l'assemblée en si tu passes au sénat les
soit ça c'est directement lié à la
personnalité
quelle est la personnalité de ceux qui
entrent en politique ou qui ont telle ou
telle responsabilité ou tel pouvoir
alors je vous parlais de la stratégie
pour conquérir le pouvoir parce que
j'aurai vous regardiez sable le champion
du monde d'échecs garry kasparov a dédié
son trophée la population arménienne et
a déclaré qu'il le vengerait aux
enchères pour leur en distribuer les
bénéfices
cela s'est fait à l'occasion d'une
cérémonie organisée au palais des
congrès de lyon où avait lieu le
championnat du monde depuis novembre
michel noir le maire sait mesurer au
champion ça n'a pas été long malgré un
handicap qui lui permettait cinq minutes
parcours lieu d'une pour son adversaire
michel noir a perdu en deux temps trois
mouvements
alors vous avez perdu mais on vous voit
là où ça vous avez envie de gagner pipe
bomb
moi j'ai le souvenir qu'on a fait une
nulle puisqu'on a terminé
couleurs reposer donc d'accord vous
seriez pas un peu mauvais perdant
bon d'accord les échecs
ça a conduit beaucoup de votre réflexion
vous allez me passer une thèse de
doctorat brillamment sur les sciences
cognitives les échecs vous rappelez du
titre de votre test parce que moi je
n'ai pas en mémoire c'était le le
bénéfices cognitifs suède la pratique du
jeu d'échecs pour les enfants pour les
enfants pourquoi parce que on revient à
ce que mon obsession depuis depuis le
début y compris comme père de famille et
comme observant de ce qui se passe
qu'est le drame le plus fort de ce pays
on revient ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure à savoir que l'échec scolaire
conduit à l'exclusion sociale d'accueil
a pas de société qu'ils puissent vivre
que dans deux des pension dont ce qu'on
sait c'est que la pratique du jeu
d'échecs développe considérablement les
capacités cognitives de l'enfant il n'ya
pas d'inégalité de capacités cognitives
chez les enfants
qui serait lié à telle ou telle chose
des handicaps liés milieu socioculturel
mais ça ne signifie pas qu'il n'ya pas
d'intelligence alors et de réseaux de
neurones au qui soit capable de
développer chez telle ou telle catégorie
d'enfants c'est faux ça vous jouer aux
échecs
la stratégie pourra conquérir le pouvoir
est un peu celle des échecs en politique
et vous vous finalement vous avez perdu
la partie aussi sur le plan et politique
puisque vous êtes retiré du jeu et ça
vous a coûté cher aussi ailleurs dans
votre vie privée dans votre vie de
famille sur le plan politique donc vous
avez été rattrapé par une affaire qui a
fait la une de l'actualité pendant de
très nombreuses années
vous avez même été condamné à de la
prison avec sursis on appelle ça on a
appelé cela la sphère des comptes
suisses c'est une affaire de famille en
plus mais c'est le cas en ce moment deux
mots de mon ex gens d'aujourd'hui je
direction bi amenant dans les pop qui
donc a trait en quelque sorte devant les
tribunaux pour parce que j'ai été sans
doute insuffisamment vigilant sur la
nature de cette personne c'est à ce
moment là qu'ils faisaient que marié
pasquet à 200% dans l'action
effectivement vous manqué sans doute
quand on est au pouvoir on dirait on
prend pas en compte qu'à part de risque
qui a confié on fait confiance à tout le
monde
le problème c'est que quand on est au
pouvoir
selon la nature des responsabilités on
est dans l'action quotidienne est
presqu'exclusivement de à tout autre
chose
oui c'est cela c'est là que on peut ne
pas avoir un esprit critique un esprit
suffisamment vigilant sur des choses qui
peuvent se passer les alliés en
confiance en vos proches c'est c'est
plus commode entre guillemets parce que
sinon c'est la suspicion donc on aider
on est plutôt européens et non pas
ottoman et vous pensez que ces produits
d'un ou le fruit d'un règlement de
compte cette histoire si ça a été révélé
c'est ce que certains médias ont honte e
s que vous avez suggéré aussi un jour
ont avancé d'un instant où les sondages
je faisais que le
ça a commencé en 1995 chirac donc oui de
90 92 nous faisait de l'ombre à
schirrhein on était il y avait déjà un
différentiel important ce plan des
sondages et vous faisait payer ce que
vous aviez tenté de faire baisser par et
novateur c'est pas la lecture que je
juge utile de faire aujourd'hui puisque
cette page là était tournée je suis
passé on en parlait cette nouvelle phase
passionnante de la vie qui consiste à
dire comment ça marche sincèrement oui
comment est-ce qu'on peut développer
toutes les qualités de l'humain et dans
l'entreprise et à l'écho sauf que ça a
eu des conséquences terribles
il ya un procès un procès d' qui vous a
vu bien vous affrontez avec votre fille
valériane c'était rude ce procès ça a
été très violent on a appelé ça dans les
gens n'ont appelé sa dynastie sur rhône
où vous souvenez où les intrigues bon de
cesser c'est une cicatrice qui encore
vivante donc une cicatrice vivante pour
vous bien sûr bien sûr c'était la femme
donc de votre gendre qui nous a trompés
il nous a trompés tout à fait donc je
crois que les les parties de ces drames
sur le plan humain qui qui vous restent
et qui vous rendent assez fréquemment
vous en voulez de ça vous en voulez de
cette période
oui oui oui bien sûr parce que d'abord
il ya rien de plus important que qu'une
famille que des enfants
et même telle ou telle responsabilité ne
vaut pas le sacrifice de donc les ce qui
s'est passé c'est bon ça pts et j'ai eu
la force de dépasser ceux ci pour
m'investir dans un tout autre itinéraire
et chants de d'investigation et de
réflexion qui est celui des
neurosciences cognitives de l'art vous
voyez plus votre fille
valériane on la voit pour des événements
familiaux importance pour lequel bon
pour un inverseur ma femme récemment ben
votre femme elle elle a résisté elle et
j'avais une feuille de papier à
cigarette entre votre femme et vos bas
c'est elle que moi on est quand même le
le le
le pilier en quelque sort de cette
famille ce qui fait que cette famille a
pu rester du vrai famille avec toutes
les valeurs que ça peut comporter moi
vos deux filles donc parce qu'il ya
julia aussi qui a été d'ailleurs qui a
eu un enfant avec pierre botton après
comme elle fait partie que intégrant
complètement de la famille d'accord donc
vous êtes un combattant vous vous êtes
un homme pressé je le disais tout à
l'heure quand en politique mais vous
êtes un homme pressé aussi pour passer à
autre chose vous finalement vous êtes
passé à autre chose
vous êtes blessé intérieurement mais on
le voit pas sur le visage comme ça vous
êtes passé à autre chose parce que vous
êtes un boulimique de la connaissance
quand on regarde ce que vous faites ce
que vous avez fait vous êtes passé vous
avez fait du théâtre vous avez joué
oncle vania ou en public vous êtes un
passionné du chose que les gens ne
savent pas laïque ou haikus et la poésie
japonaise et vous avez écrit ceci
lorsque l'on croit même la douleur est
source de joie c'est plus votre vie ou
passé
c'est une belle image de ce qu on peut
être dans la vie et que chacun doit
vivre sans doute parce que on a tous des
douleurs de les formes différentes dans
une vie bien évidemment est ce cette
année coup je les écris une nuit
quelques jours avant l'arrivée en france
qui de jean paul 2 qui venait pour une
visite j'étais au gouvernement et on
j'écrivais et j'ai écrit un recueil de
douze haïkus comme ça en en quelques
jours que qu'avec ma femme on a offert
au saint père quand il est arrivé à lyon
donc le saint père a eu ce recueil de
haïkus le nom du recueil
non non a cédé simplement simplement 12
et un coup pour pour le saint père vous
êtes très croyant pardon vous êtes très
croyant difficile à dire
ça vous a aidé la fois dans les épreuves
que vous allez traverser ce qui m'a aidé
surtout c'est le sait le volet familial
parce que quand vous avez été élevé sous
le sigle n'oublie jamais mathausen vous
avez une résilience forte capacité de
résilience que considérable donc ça
c'est sans doute encore plus fort que
telle ou telle foi qui est une trace au
fond de beaucoup de dents d'entre nous
même si on n'est pas pratique en quelque
sorte parce que parce qu'il faut croire
en l'homme n'oublie jamais mathausen
c'est une façon de se dire quand on est
gamin il faut changer cette société il
faut et je veux je veux remettre je veux
participer je veux justement avoir une
part du pouvoir pour demande c'est pour
ça qu'on mangera en politique
oui c'est pour ça que on se dit qu'il ya
de plus important que réussir l'enfant
c'est pour ça qu'on se dit compte tenu
de ce qu'est l'état des sciences sur le
plan du cerveau du community
comment ne pas en tenir compte dans la
manière dont fonctionnent les
entreprises et dont on doit développer
les compétences
des personnes et dont toi on doit
s'organiser pour que chacun soit obtenue
dans ses compétences
et puis se développer ses compétences ce
qui est le contraire de ce qu est la
structure hiérarchique de pouvoir
classique qu'on peut avoir de
l'entreprise ouais c'est pas les mêmes
recettes dans l'entreprise et dans la
politique c'est pas le même maintenant
vous êtes un patron d'entreprise qui
marche très très fort d'ailleurs un
c'est une entreprise donc scientific
brain training entreprises ont quand
même deux personnes c'est une belle
réussite oui mais vous marché
international mais ça se sait ce guide
de la même façon une municipalité en
entreprise le politique a un métro de
retard
ou peut-être un tgv de retard par
rapport à ce qui est en train de se
passer dans l'entreprise on s'aperçoit
que c'est pas l'organisation qui compte
c'est pas du tout le pouvoir les hacher
qui compte c'est l'humain les
compétences qu'on peut faire éclore en
chacun et le fait que ensemble donc en
travaillant en équipe et sur projet et
avec un niveau de responsabilité
dédié à chaque équipe à chacun on donne
du sens à ce qu'elle une l'objet d'une
entreprise alors je disais que vous
voulez une version complète de valeur
vous aviez un appétit d'ogre
d'ailleurs vous êtes et cécilia vous
êtes sans doute servi un peu dans la vie
beau gosse grand vous remarquer c'est
vrai c'est vous qui jouez vous savez
tout ça parce que je sers à 97 et son
pilot bombe de 500 kilos pour 1 mètre 90
est ce quelqu'un veut des lancers vous
êtes un boulimique vous alors je disais
les haïkus le jules leleu les polars
vous écrivez que la route pour las le
théâtre des pièces d'auteurs et vous
apprenez le russe en plus je l'avais
appris quand j'étais au lycée
et puis là comme j'ai un petit peu de
temps de libre je me suis remis parce
que c'est d'abord j'ai adoré la
littérature russe et ensuite les
et c'est une langue ayant pratiqué par
la prise commencé à apprendre pendant de
la 4e à la terminale
je suis dit ça serait quand même dommage
de ne pas réveiller tout ceci tellement
c'est une mais vous vous donniez là en
russe vous parlez meriem no go ouais
d'accord pas trop mal vous êtes un homme
pressé en fait vous avez toujours été un
homme pressé quatre n'ont pas apprécié
du tout ce que je dis c'est un jour sur
le livre d'or de l'heure de vérité de la
l2 confrères célèbre heure de vérité
quelle année 89
vous connaissez la juin 89 parce que
vous avez une mémoire d'éléphant aussi
ça c'est les sciences à des 18 juin en
plus qu'on se souvenir non pas de
waterloo mais de de l'appel du général
de gaulle
j'ai écrit chaque jour le courage
d'apprendre parce que je trouve que
chaque jour il y avait des choses à
apprendre
en venant ici depuis le la place
voltaire j'ai appris deux trois petits
trucs deux trois petites choses comme ça
est ce que vous avez appris quelque
chose sur vous même dans cet entretien
pack le plus simple c'est d'être soi
même et il peut avoir envie de faire
semblant de ou de tricher dans les
réponses ton père il ya six chinois
merci beaucoup
[Musique]